home
okay hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome to Mr Hopps Manor
Escape I have not played Mr Hopps
something something something two I
played the demo to it but the full game
did come out and then I saw that this
game also came out a little bit later
and it seemed to be more focused on a
Pure Escape thing sorry if something in
my nose
so what this whoa hi thank you what did
I get oh I oh wait I wait wait wait wait
I didn't get to change any settings also
it's gonna get really hot in here hang
on I gotta go turn on the air
[Music]
nothing bad happens while I'm away
[Music]
foreign
things spooky happened
okay so it doesn't matter what you do it
just does that
hello
[Music]
what what is happening
what
[Music]
okay
I don't know what's happening it's just
it's controlling a little s a little
differently than I would have imagined
it would
what did I do
[Music]
I guess I'm going into practice
it's probably important because I don't
know how to play this game
so I'm just guessing that this is
intentional
oh good hi
well well well ah
[Music]
it's probably not a good thing to do
[Music]
hmm I need three stone tablets to open
this door is that a knife that's a
screwdriver
all right then what do I do with the
screwdriver why do I hold it above my
head like that it's not a pack of
cigarettes
Maybe
oh
ah
[Music]
oh
I don't know man I don't know so I'm in
a manner and I'm trying
kind of odd that that just floats above
my head like that but all right and I'm
trying to escape right at the general
Crux of the idea so I can't pick up
anything else until I get rid of the
screwdriver in my hand
uh-huh
okay
uh-huh
this is strange
the ice sculpture has a key in it so
smash it okay there's something at the
top of that pillar
ah that might be one of the stone
tablets
I think anyway okay so I gotta figure
out some way to get up there
whoa that did not look right I need
something heavy
well
how about this
no okay
can I oh oh
fuse okay so I can drop with f that's
what I can do
I don't imagine That's Heavy
I don't imagine this is heavy okay let
me actually back up let me see if I can
do uh normal because I don't really want
to practice here I want to do something
ah there we go okay
ah I can I see I see I see okay Mr hop
is enabled
whatever that means well actually I know
exactly what that means it means that
they're gonna come after me and try to
kill me which is always great to see
all right come after me I'm ready for
you wherever you are
how aware of my surroundings do I need
to be oh this is different
oh my God
oh my God
oh hi Mr hop hi
I'm just gonna
oh my God
screw that
screw that TV needs powerful I don't
know what I just did
I've cursed myself and my future project
hey
okay all right okay all right okay all
right what is this I got coal wow I've
I'm so happy I have a lump of coal great
what do I do with that do I do anything
with that okay this is where that is
maybe there's some way to burn that or
something I'll leave the coal there for
now
ah oh maybe I took the cold down to the
basement that looked like it might have
some kind of a furnacey thing to it
that'd probably be a good idea
okay rad is guarding something I could
pry off the boards
um uh that's one of those things
whatever that does
ah
the place open this and replace a few so
screwdriver to open that and then
replace it with a fuse and I bet there's
some kind of like
Flinter Steelers something that could
light that probably probably okay
foreign
something is inside this mirror what
what do you mean
what do you mean something
what would be inside the mirror what are
you talking about
like that
I don't like that
I don't like that
is there anything in here no that's
where I got the coal okay
so it's a randomly generated experience
oh dangerous Miracles by what does that
mean
what do you mean
what do you mean danger is very close by
that's a very specific statement to make
and I don't know what you're talking
about
[Music]
so it was nothing as it turns out it was
actually nothing
unless you're just [ __ ] with me
oh that's what you mean
okay why that didn't help me
God all right then whatever you say
[ __ ]
I don't like you I don't like you at all
I don't like you
oh God oh God oh God okay
um well this was not a good idea
um okay
um all right
okay seems to be gone
nothing in here nothing in here
okay
I'm gonna go for it now I'm going for it
I'm gone
for it get that
[Music]
okay oh that's a fuse I know what to do
with that wow I need to get the
screwdriver before I can replace it
probably
okay oh that I don't like I could cut
this but why though
what is I picked up a book great
I don't know what to do with that
all right I'm gonna try and get this
fuse back
I'm gonna try to get this fuse back to
where it needs to go
um
and then I don't know wow why
and then I guess I'll die maybe I could
take the hammer I can I could smash the
ice sculpture that might be what it
wants me to do with that I just don't
know yet
but I will experiment to find out I'll
leave this here I need the screwdriver
to be able to do that
so I gotta wait
oh my God he big he big he real big he
he's a big boy oh where'd that hammer go
where did I put the hammer
Hammer Time okay
and back down
and back down and back down okay ice
sculpture was somewhere
[Music]
okay maybe I'll try that again later
maybe I'll try that again later maybe
I'll go somewhere else first and I'll
try that again later maybe I'll do that
let me maybe I'll suck up the power of
the ethereals
all right good
I've got a a statue great oh something
heavy okay if I find the uh Library
again that should help me
I just don't know where that is isn't
that
wait I suck painting piece I swear I saw
a painting somewhere here oh God oh God
I swear I saw a painting somewhere here
if this is yeah right here that's one of
those painting pieces I don't know what
that's about but I found it so I might
as well do it I guess
hello is that a gramama phone is this a
dead end that would kill me yes 100
well I'm gonna
God damn having three of those things in
here would be a nightmare which I guess
is kind of the point but whatever yes
let's try this
damn I thought that was gonna be it
okay apparently not uh I don't know
where else the hammer would be
um maybe the boards here
good to know
oh
Schwab I am
I have a freaking Barrel
come here Mr hops I'm about to show you
what for
I don't know what that's about I don't
know why I would be carrying that all
over the place with me that seems
extremely excessive
but hey a barrel
[Music]
oh oh no
no take my Barrel
good God there's nowhere to hide here oh
my God oh my God I'm I'm dead I'm a dead
child
hello
okay we're fine I guess
he's gonna grab this barrel and be on my
way
oh
oh
[Music]
oh oh he's a bad idea
hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy oh God
you'll never notice the bear
oh okay I'm going for it
bye
goodbye
wow this is working out much more
effectively than I thought it would
wow
wow again don't really know what it's
for but I have it which is great there's
got to be a library around here
somewhere oh scissors I could use that
to cut the cord I think
anything in here up outside I didn't
suspect that I would ever get outside
can I go home
can I go home now
this needs a key okay probably the key
from the statue
um
barrel
barrel Apple
put in Barrel
why would I need an apple
maybe the mouse I guess
but a mouse would really want an apple
uh let me go grab an apple and bring it
in with me at least a little bit that
way I can get some kind of an idea of
what I would need to do with this
okay I'll put it here
hmm
there's the screwdriver that's good
there's a big suit of armor ah
I need the marble bust and the barrel to
be able to press down there were two
pressure plates my brain is working at
full capacity there were two pressure
plates one of them needed a barrel in
the other I can get it I can get it oh
no
[Music]
it's fine
it is A-Okay where was it was it here
yeah here
okay need something heavy how about this
Wham oh
and I bet I need the book
where are you where are you oh hey
um hi how about that uh don't mind me
what do you mean what do you what do you
mean what do you mean the open hallway
is locked
how about that
okay hey the other painting piece God
there's a lot of stuff here
God there's too much stuff here
how am I supposed to be able to do
anything oh what do you mean that's
locked
what do you mean
oh
oh no
oh my God
holy crap
[Music]
well
that was interesting let's try that
again
oh I don't like the sound of that
I'm guessing that sound means danger is
very close by and I should pay attention
to that sound because that sound is a
cue that I need to pay attention to
all right probably fine now let's get
out of here okay never mind then going
back in the closet all right Danger's
probably passed by now haha knew it I'm
some kind of a genius
I don't remember where I put the barrel
but I do have this painting piece and I
can go get that in the spot that it
needs to be in
oh thank you I have five of the six
magical symbols
that's good
oh this is not fine
I have a bucket
okay fine oh that was not a good idea
to go get the barrel oh man if I could
stop making noise for one second
Barrel
got you
Barrel
oh that's not good
it was by the suit of armor I think
here we go now what did that do
[Music]
you tell me
that that heavy ass Barrel ain't cutting
the mustard is that what you're telling
me this
big ass Barrel
ain't doing the job is that what you're
telling me the gigantic Barrel
the extremely
Hefty Barrel
you ain't doing that okay whatever you
say
oh I don't know the combination to you I
don't know what you're for valve
make Half-Life 3 damn it I don't know
what this pack of cigarettes is for
box of matches okay the box of matches
definitely go start the pilot light
that's down there oh God
oh no no no no no no
can you please get out of me way
I didn't know
oh God
[Applause]
oh my God oh God
I'm in the closet you don't know
oh fool you fool you fool you falling
right into my trap
I've got so many things
that I need to go all the things that I
need are in the far right where he is
and I need to take him all the way over
to the far left where I'm not one at a
time which I find to be a little bit
annoying
but it's fine the sufferings of random
generation shall not stop me from
completing whatever my mission is which
I guess is escaping okay
got that fuse going you wham bam
I guess that's good now but I don't
really know what that did so I'm gonna
go get the box of matches and then I'm
going to try to light that pilot fire
and maybe that will turn the heat up in
the house and maybe that will melt the
goose and maybe that will allow me to
get out of here
maybe okay
is it really so dangerous I didn't think
so oh
all right maybe I'll go uh for a little
bit of a detour up north and I'll go
upstairs and oh
get him up traveling around this circuit
for oh I don't have the scissors
okay
it's fine all right maybe I'll just like
juggle things over to the left because I
do need the scissors but I also need the
box of matches but many things that I
need apparently a box of matches okay
got that I think uh there was the valve
as well maybe that has something to do
with the boiler
I don't know
it's annoying that they're all over here
I'm gonna go light the pile of light but
I have a funny feeling that I'm gonna
need to get that valve as well
it's probably just better for my sanity
if I do it one at a time even if it's a
long journey or do is even I might as
well do it and I might need that hammer
like there was that crack in the wall
and I'm wondering if the hammer was part
of it
I'm gonna go uh once I light the fire I
will put the I'll bring the hammer back
over there so I can see if that's a part
of it it may not be but not like it
takes me any more work
yes I know which is why I have matches
it's why I have matches maybe I do need
the valve for that oh grab the hammer
and maybe bring an apple order over if I
feel like it I guess too many things
need
cream that out in the
end all right let's go smash a hole in
the wall what's the worst could happen
I could die I guess damn oh come on
here that'd be it I still don't know
what the Barrel's about ooh I bet I I'm
what I do I bet I cut the rope
I bet I cut the rope use that on the the
bucket and I bet there's some kind of a
well that I gotta draw water from or
something like that I bet that's part of
it
or it's not and I'm being stupid which
is also just as likely okay boiler Wham
there we go light ah
let's see if that did the thing uh did I
pass it already was it like the far one
oh damn it I passed sorry didn't I
was here damn it this one
it was right there hey look at that I
bet this is the key trap door key what
do you mean trapdorky
what do you mean trapdorky what trap
door
what was a trap door what are you
talking about trapdoor key what do you
mean trapdoor tell me what you mean all
right what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna go
grab the scissors
oh he's gonna come for that I forgot
yeah I could use the noise a bit better
to draw him away from things oh my God
oh my God oh my God oh my God
oh my God okay
so there was a uh um
there's nothing up here was there no I
already got everything that I needed up
here except the book
it was a book right okay I got a robe
and there was a book I don't know what
the book is for but I there's a book in
a rope up here
my God
it's fine it's fine it's fine can I use
this on oh I don't know I don't know
okay the only thing that I I saw that
needed a key was the door outside but I
don't think that's gonna be the one
because this says trap door key and
that's very different
not this
needs a key
no trapdoor key is not these things
maybe there's a trap door under the sand
and I use the bucket to scoop it out I'm
grasping at straws but that's all I got
at the moment
now
I have a funny feeling that I need this
out here and I'm gonna grab this key
because otherwise I'm never gonna see it
again
so there must be a trapdoor somewhere in
the house there's something in the
mirror
the mirror right
maybe if I I remember there being
something about the mirror so if I go
grab the hammer and I go find that
mirror and I smash it
was that in the previous game or was it
in this one I don't remember
[Music]
oh TV
7370 okay that's progress 737-0 because
I turned on power to the house 7370 okay
remember that everybody seven three
seven zero let me see if I can find that
mirror this mirror
oh
whoa
shenky
shanky
shed key now unlocked oh
yes got
gasoline rake
I don't know 100 know what these are for
various gardening tools and gasoline not
like I need to light anything on fire or
fuel anything up and the rake you know
maybe I could put it on the ground so
that Mr Hopps comically steps on it and
it slams him in the nose I mean that's
about the only thing that I can think of
but 7370 is something that can help me
is then I can go over here and I can
open up the safe right here
seven
three oh
what'd I get
hey that that's that's one of them the
rake I can get the thing off the top of
the thing I can get The Medallion off
the top of the thing how could I not
think of that of course you could I
needed something extendable to be able
to get to that and that's just about as
extendable as I could possibly hope for
is this going to work
hey there we go
handy dandy that well well well
looks like I'm about to win all right so
I've got gasoline there's the thing
about the mouse I could probably I'm
gonna try the Apple I don't really have
any other piece of like cheese or
anything like that apple is the only
thing that I could think
you would be able to feed
to a mouse
well you're not so scary you're not so
scary you're not so scary
thank you
so if the mouse is guarding
oh ah oh
hey hey hey okay
okay it's gone okay
so if the mouse is guarding something
so if the mouse is guarding something
that means that there's something even
deeper in that hole that I need to get
and either I need to use a rake to get
it or it's going to give it to me myself
Mouse
hey oh Pinky
thanks mouse that was awfully convenient
of you hope you enjoyed the Apple thank
you that helps a lot I think maybe
there's a way that I could fuel up a car
and get out of here
oh boy
if I may be so bold
oh I'm being too bold
Oh I thought you had a gun
I thought you had a gun
I thought you had a gun to my head like
legitimately was like Mr hop as a
freaking gun oh okay cool guess we're
fine there
oh good
and a gem wow trap door I don't know why
there's a trap door locked behind a gate
give me give me give me give me give me
give me give me give me
but I'm gonna find out seems like an
awfully convoluted path just to be able
to get to this key unlocked
oh
hey what are you doing
I'm what
what
[Music]
oh
oh
[Music]
oh
oh I'm not I'm not actually gonna play
again but I was I was just kind of
trying to see what the difference is I
didn't know that that would be an actual
Escape I thought that was going to be
something where I could like I don't
know find another item but I didn't
realize that there were multiple ways to
get out
oh I still only started with the same
number of lives interesting huh so there
was a way to get out from the front door
um oh but it's randomly generated the
basement is here of all places
that's funky
oh my God hi oh okay all right well I
guess this is it for all Isaac oh God
all right well so that was Mr hopp's
Manor Escape
not bad I like it more as a contained
experience versus like
um actually no I like it as a contained
experience no qualifier there's no
comparatives that I have to say there I
I never got around to Playing Mr Ops 2.
I do want to at some point because I I
feel like it was a good game and I I
liked the demo but if you guys want to
see it I will definitely play it for you
let me know down in the comments what
you thought thank you everybody so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]